recently I had the honor of interviewing
big game James Worthy at an event of
ours and I have to tell you I was blown
away by the stories he was telling me
and in this session here he talks about
an element of he and magic working
together when he first came to the
Lakers leaving the Tar Heels and how he
had to learn and adjust his leadership
position for the Lakers to become the
winning team that they became I think
you're going to be very intrigued by the
stories he shares you about leadership
I was one of those that came into an
environment from college coming from
college being the leader being the guy
that everyone followed and everyone
looked to for guidance and direction I
was that guy so when I came to Los
Angeles I knew I could play I had been
drafted number one so all my work had
been proven so when I came to Los
Angeles all I wanted to do was hold my
talent and make my contribution to the
team now I didn't want to listen to
someone say hey we need to get together
and go out to dinner as a team or as a
team we need to build character so let's
go to the movies or let's hang out
together off the court that wasn't my
thing neither did I want to listen to
too much in practice I want to listen to
the coach and I want to listen to the
owner and I listen to the general
manager but I didn't want to listen to
so like a guy like Magic Johnson too
much because I just wanted to play my
game and it took me a few years to
understand that he was a true leader and
that even though I had been a leader I
had to come a follower again because
this was magic team and everyone knew
that I was a really good player but I
was also a long wolf and it was working
out we had won a championship but in
order to sustain it you know my name
came up in a trade and therefore I had
to go sit now magic and have lunch with
him and and I had to realize that all he
was trying to do was connect the team
into one
you can have five guys but when you
really put five guys together you got a
really mighty strong fist below and
that's what magic had to convey to me he
wasn't trying to overrule me or have
authority he was the leader and once I
understood that it made me better it
made me a better person event teammate
and a better player and ultimately it
made our business and our brand